fin de série pour le Pyroman récidiviste
un suspect de 50 ans vient d'être
interpellé pour une vingtaine d'incendie
et des voitures et des cabanons à la
riche mais aussi un club house celui du
stade Jules Ferry a Joué-lès-Tours déjà
condamné pour des faits similaires en
2017 l'homme sera jugé le 9 août
prochain les précisions de Romainville
c'était le 15 juin dernier dans la
soirée des bureaux une salle de
réception au stade Jules Ferry de jouer
les tours par téton fumée un homme placé
en garde à vue avant-hier a reconnu
l'effet et bien plus encore cet homme de
51 ans domicile et à la riche serait à
l'origine de l'incendie de 8 véhicules
d'une dizaine de cabanons sur la riche
saint genou et jouer les tours des
dégradations sur une dizaine de voitures
dans le quartier des Minimes crevaison
rayures pourrait en outre lui être
imputé depuis le mois de février une
enquête fine de l'unité des atteintes au
bien lui a B a pu le confondre après son
interpellation en flagrance au début du
mois de juillet le la riche choix déjà
été condamné en juin 2018 pour des faits
similaires il était l'incendiaire de
véhicules à blairer et relaxer quelques
mois plus tôt faute de preuves dans les
incendies de voitures dans le quartier
des Halles son procès pour incendie
volontaire et dégradation par moyens
incendiaires et programmer le mercredi 9
août